- By the way, congratulations.
- Thank you!
(clapping and cheering)
Can you... I can't believe it.
I mean, even from the very first...
it's been seventeen years first of all.
- What?
- That is crazy.
- What is that? Are we old?
You can have it.
- Thank you.
- I haven't drank out of it.
It's Essentia Water if you like it.
- You might want to get a rabies shot.
- It's been seventeen years, y'all,
I would have never thought that show
would have had the impact.
I mean look at what it did,
the domino effect was crazy.
- I actually genuinely do not believe
we would be sitting here today
if you hadn't entered the show that year.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Not true.
- But, I mean, the whole
premise of the show was
we had to find a star who
was gonna sell records.
We found some great
people that whole year,
but when you delivered that
moment on that first live show,
and when you sang that
winning song at the end--
- It was a game changer.
- We looked at each other
at the end, at the finale,
and said, "wow," this
thing is really gonna work.
I think that was the moment that we knew.
- Wasn't it crazy, cause I remember
Nikki and Justin and I, we had no idea.
We ended up being the top three,
and we had no idea the show
had blown up like it had,
because we were all in that bubble.
At Kodak Theater, I think
that's when it hit all of us.
We were like, wait, what?
People know my name?
- We were sitting in the balcony.
- [Kelly] Y'all were in the balcony.
- Simon put us in the balcony--
- Oh, no, no, no. So yes,
so we turned up at that
night, at the final.
And we were looking forward
to it, thinking, you know,
we've worked hard to get to this point.
We turn up at the Dolby Theater,
where I saw you a couple of weeks ago.
- Yeah.
- And we were taken to
the very, very, very top
of the theater.
- The nose bleeds.
- And I was like, "How can
we judge the show from here?"
And they went, "You're not judging it."
And we went, "Well, what
are we supposed to be doing?
Just watch?"
- They told Justin and I
we were doing that duet
that we did live, on
live national television
like three minutes before live national
television started.
- What?
You didn't even know?
- No, literally we were
both standing there
we were like, "What"?
- Do you guys remember where we saw her?
It was like a VFW, like a veteran's hall.
- [Paula] Yes.
- Like really, we really--
- That was the craziest day
of your life.
- I remember
what you were wearing, Kelly.
- We literally started from
the bottom and now we're here.
- I freaked out, cause I was like,
"Who is the English guy"?
Like, when I walked in, I'll
tell you, I knew nothing.
I literally had just moved back from L.A.
My place had burned down,
I was living in my car
for three days here.
And then finally, I was
like I gotta go home.
And somebody told me about the audition,
and I literally walked in,
I had no idea what I was doing
I didn't know it was a T.V. show
until the audition I
was in front of y'all.
I was like, Paula Abdul
is here, some Simon dude.
- Yes, um--
- [Kelly] He's just some English dude.
(audience cheering)
- I also did recognize Randy
because I knew he had played with Mariah
and I was like, "Oh,
snap, what's happening?"
- Didn't you reverse roles or something?
- I did.
- You were sitting behind the curtain.
- I got a little nervous
because y'all asked me
to sing another song.
'Cause I sang "At Last" and you said,
"sing another song."
And I literally sat there going
sing any song but "itchie, gitchie ya-ya"
cause everyone was singing that
♪ "Itchie, gitchie ya-ya" ♪
Everyone was doing "Lady
Marmalade" and I was like,
any song but that, and
then out of nowhere,
"Express Yourself" came out.
I don't know why.
- That was like of the most exciting days,
but I have another--
- Well, and on that day
when she auditioned,
I knew you were gonna win.
- Oh really, well I happened to--
- No you didn't.
- I did.
I never watch these shows.
But I saw some woman named Callie,
an older woman on America's Got Talent
that was unbelievable the other day.
She's like 60 years old, or something.
She's ridiculously good, Simon.
- Who?
- And you stood up, who?
You stood up and gave
her a standing ovation.
- That was Paula at the VMAs.
(laughter)
- Paula?
- You got the shows mixed up.